alright guys so I wanted to share my
thoughts with you on this Freddie gray
situation and the Baltimore riots that
are happening literally as I speak you
know what this is made me realize is
that two things can be true at once so
there was an incredible miscarriage of
justice here in that there was no
justice what happened to Freddie gray is
inexcusable and we have seen several
other examples in the last year
especially of this kind of thing the
black community feels like they're under
assault rightfully so we definitely have
we still have racial problems in the
country obviously but there seems to be
something systemic going on with law
enforcement and I don't want to only
blame law enforcement because we also
need law enforcement for a lot of things
but it seems that two things can be true
here because on one hand we see people
that are only focusing on what happened
to Freddie and not focusing on the
rioters which is awful also right and
then there are people that are only
focusing on the rioters and not focusing
on Freddie which is what precipitated
all this and I think two things can be
true at once here so we do need to all
as a country our media our politicians
us as citizens need to think about more
about how this type of stuff and this
this race what appears to be racial
injustice happening consistently why is
this happening we need to focus on that
and then at the same time we need to
also step up and acknowledge that when
these things happen that we still can't
be rioting and ransacking through our
cities and I know a lot of people would
argue well that's the only way you can
get the system to change I I personally
don't believe that I hope that's not how
it has to happen that to get change we
have to literally destroy stores I mean
people are destroying stores in their
own communities right now you know
destroying local CVS is and liquor sois
that that doesn't make anything change
that makes the system hit back harder so
there's a lot here but two things can be
true and we can focus on both of those
things making justice for Freddie happen
and in and hopefully that stops future
cases like this and also stopping the
rioting which actually isn't helping
people think the media is driven by some
agenda I think the media is basically
driven by what people will watch and
what people click on so if a building is
burning or if a car is burning or there
are people attacking a cop car then yeah
they are going to focus on that because
that's what people watch and then it
deflects from actually what the more
important issue is which is getting
justice for Freddie which it's too late
for him to get justice but getting
justice for the next Freddie so I think
we all can do better and that's what I'm
trying to put out there and that's what
I hope you guys try to put out there